great Thank You Ava thank you to Steven
and Balaji and David for putting
together the workshop and inviting me
I'm pretty excited to talk about this
works it's actually the first talk that
any of us is giving on this work it's
relatively recent so feedback is very
welcome my collaborators on the work are
virag and Jose Jose is sitting there
virag I think was here there he is
and so yeah definitely any mistakes are
my own and any credit should go to the
two of them so the motivation for the
work is actually I mean there's two ways
to look at it so I'll kind of describe
to you first of all what my own
motivation was and then maybe how this
embeds within a broader context so my
own motivation I mean here's a wide
range of online platforms and this I've
generally been quite interested in
thinking about the design and operation
of these platforms over the last seven
years or so and one of the things that I
kind of find interesting is that usually
these platforms will use various types
of learning algorithms to determine how
to recommend items or you know jobs or
alternatives to users and you know these
algorithms that the way that they're
usually developed at least to the extent
that one can prove anything about them
the the the types of guarantees we
provide are typically under the
presumption that the arrivals are not
influenced by the decisions that you
make and in many of these platforms that
turns out to be a pretty poor assumption
which is you know that one of the things
that is is fairly common especially for
platforms that maybe are in an earlier
middle stage of their life cycle is that
positive experiences by certain types of
users will tend to attract more users of
the same type
it's very common if you're talking to
you know especially kind of folks in
industry that work around these
platforms that these sorts of network
effects in the population that they're
trying to attract are one of the big
things that they think about
strategically now we titled the talk
bandit learning with positive
externalities I didn't want to use the
phrase network effects because there's
no network in the talk per se I think us
whose talk is much
want to talk about network games this is
so I used the phrase positive
externalities to refer to this kind of
positive reinforcing behavior so that
was my you know that was kind of the
more applied motivation for it now in
terms of like the context that sits
within one of the things I find
interesting about this and I think that
that might be a launching point to think
about other types of problems that are
related is that is really this point
that arrivals are not influenced by
decisions because if you take this to
its extreme and you take you know
typical multi-armed bandit problems and
then change the feature that the arrival
process is sort of independent of the
decisions you're making you basically
are in the worst case you're kind of all
the way over to fold reinforcement
learning because now the actions you're
taking our influence what's happening in
the future so there's delayed
consequences and you know to make
progress in this type of a problem you
need I think some type of structure if
you want to give kind of sharp
guarantees so this is a nice kind of you
know mathematical model where there's
enough structure to be able to say
something very precise ok so those are
kind of two different ways to situate
what the work is all about
so the first two slides here I'm just
going to set up for you what one of the
main points of the talk is with a very
very simple example that illustrates
kind of how positive externalities play
a role in the analysis that we do so
suppose there's two types of users blu
users like blue items but not red items
and red users like red items but not
blue items okay and you know in a
nutshell if you ask yourself what could
go wrong in using a typical learning
algorithm that kind of is ignoring this
self reinforcement effect here are the
basic issues so if you make a red red
match early on let's say then there are
two things that happen there's kind of
two effects that simultaneously will
start to play out as a consequence of
that effect of that match and actually
sorry the service said suppose a
successful red red match is made early
on okay so when I say a red red match
you can imagine there's some
stochasticity and the outcome you know
just assume this was a good match okay
now the first thing is the positive
externality says that when red type
users have good experiences that tends
to attract more users of the same type
in the future so that'll mean that more
red type or what users are likely to
arrive because of this single event but
the other thing that happens is that
because more of these users are arriving
should the platform choose to show blue
items it will generate less reward on
those choices on those on those
instances okay
so essentially both of these if you know
these these kind of phenomena what they
do is they push the platform in the
direction of preferring red red matches
okay now this is you know very kind of
high-level and hand wavy and you could
you know it begs a lot of questions
which is well ok yes this is obviously
structured to make a particular point
does this really matter is this a thing
that anyone should actually worry about
and this wasn't you know for Hosea and
Vera organized this was kind of the
launching point of asking well is there
is there something here you know I mean
obviously one answer to this might be
yes in principle this could happen but
it's actually not interesting now since
I still have like 25 minutes left you
know something must have happened and
that's that's what I'll tell you about
over the rest of the talk ok so yeah and
just to just emphasize in the case where
in fact blue blue matches are more
valuable to the platform this would be a
suboptimal outcome from the perspective
of reward just one thing I'll mention
before I go away from the motivation
because the rest of the talk will really
just be in the kind of mathematical
model setting but I one of the reasons I
find this model fascinating is it is a
good prompt for lots of other
conversations I mean just making a
statement like this already forecasts
that I'm going to care about the
platform maximizing reward but you can
see that this set up and this kind of
self reinforcement and who is seeing
what is very closely related to much of
the discussion on polarization and those
types of dynamics and so you could think
of other objective functions that might
be interesting here as well from the
perspective of learning none of what I'm
doing in this talk so in that sense
that's you know again why I feel like
it's really the tip of a much larger
iceberg of how these self reinforcing
processes influence learning ok so
here's the summary of our results
basically just two main things I'm going
to tell you although you'll see that it
breaks down into many many smaller
results along the way one of them is
that optimal algorithms for the standard
multi-armed bandit can fail
spectacularly so the first answer that
I'm giving you here is yes the thing I
told you in the last two slides actually
is a problem and it can't happen but the
other is I'll fill in for you what I
mean by spectacularly as we as we go
along and then you know given that
that's the case that begs the question
also what would a good algorithm look
like and we basically characterized
a good algorithm and a matching liver
panel okay so what is the model the
model is a fairly straightforward
generalization of what I showed you in
that in that simple example and so let
me fill that in we'll start with all the
stuff that's classical so everything
that that you would write down for a
standard multi-armed bandit problem and
by the way I'm very grateful to the
speakers who came before me this week
Rahul in particular Rahul Jain on Monday
there was plenty of discussion of
multi-armed bandit some kind of
presuming that you know some of that is
already background at this point so n is
the number of arms T is the discrete
time horizon where I'm going to assume
that one user is arriving per time step
that I can take an action on mu a is the
probability of unit reward when armed a
is pulled and and basically I'm thinking
of this is then a Bernoulli outcome it's
a it's a it's a zero one reward that I
get it when I pull an arm I want you to
to pause on this for a second I
specifically wrote standard bandit here
because this is what we mean in the
standard bandit model I'm obviously
gonna have to tell you a little bit more
about this one we think about positive
externalities that'll be the next slide
okay a star is going to denote the best
arm for simplicity we'll assume that's
unique that's not really that
consequential and then two additional
pieces of notation that denote the
number of to know there's a spider
that's actually walking down my slide as
I go so so T a of T is the number of
times that arm a is pulled or
recommended up to time T so think of
these arms as items think of pulling as
recommendation and then si of T is the
number of times that I actually get a
reward on arm a okay crucially the
platform of course doesn't you know it's
its goal is going to be to think about
maximizing its expected reward as I as I
hinted at earlier over that time horizon
and then all of our analysis is done
asymptotic in T so we're not providing
finite time bounds here okay all right
oh and I guess one other comment I
should make is the just because of time
I'm not really saying anything about
related work we have an archive paper up
there's lots of different connections
from this type of work to you know
particularly the literature on network
effects in the literature on bandit
learning and you know I'm happy to talk
more about that offline if you'd like
okay so what is the model of positive
externalities what
we do is we first assume that there's
initial bias on each arm that's theta a
and you assume that all L these are
strictly positive and then what we
assume is that the user arriving at time
T likes an arm a with a probability
which is proportional to some function
that depends on that initial bias and
the number of the total rewards that
you've earned on that arm up to this
time okay so this is that element of
self reinforcement if people you know if
RMA has generated positive rewards then
people who arrive subsequently are more
likely to like arm a now what does like
mean I need to translate that into the
Preferences of this person and how that
influences the Bandit so here's the key
the idea is that if I use our likes arm
a alright then I kind of have the
standard bandit model mu a is the
probability of generating a reward when
I pull arm a for this user the the
difference is what if this user does not
like arm a in that case I get nothing
when I pull arm a okay so there's two
ways that an arm can fail here one way
is that the user simply doesn't like the
arm alright and then the other way that
the arm a can fail is that these are
does like the arm but it happened to be
one of those cases where randomly you
just didn't get a reward right so the
second of those is the thing that looks
like the standard bandit model and that
first one is the positive externality
effect yeah yeah this is a great
question I was actually about to talk
about a couple of assumptions that are
baked into this that are not explicit so
this is a good one no no it's good that
you asked that question let me talk
about a simpler one first and I'll come
back to this real quick so one thing I
wanted to point out is that the way this
is set up it's if you think about what
this means it means the expected number
of arms preferred by a user is one okay
and that's just sort of a feature of
this normalization you can start
thinking about other positive
externality models that would sort of
depart from that so now Ava's question
is a great one and I'm going to reframe
it slightly there's kind of built into
this whole thing a capacity constraint
right which is basically that users
arriving sequentially every period and
as she pointed out in our in our model
we're not kind of allowing the
possibility
the rate of user arrival slows down or
speeds up and you know in some sense
there's the platform knows for sure it's
going to have tea service opportunities
it's not going to have any more than
that and it's not going to have any less
than that okay and both directions I
think are interesting to think about so
the capacity constraint is really
interesting because that's one of the
things that drives trying to find the
best arm in the first place and then in
the other direction what you said is
really interesting because that might
mean that despite having tea service
opportunities I actually can't take
advantage of all of them because I've
driven people away so yet I think those
are certainly important ways in which
our model is stylized ok all right so f
is what I'm going to call the
externality function it determines the
strength of this positive externality
right and you know for basically
everything I do up until the last couple
slides of the talk I'm going to assume
that F is just X just linear in general
we consider X that are X to the Alpha
with the exception of one result where
I'll mentioned you that holds for more
general if ok ok so since I'm studying
performance that's asymptotic and T you
know it's it's natural basically to
think of a baseline Oracle where I'm
always choosing RMA star now this
clearly may not be optimal on finite
time horizons right because of the bias
I mean if the bias is really really
strong in a direction away from a star
and T is very small I know I shouldn't
pull a star but asymptotically at least
it seems plausible that a star always
pulling a star asymptotically would be
the right thing to do because you can
move the population over to two liking a
star and so we we just as a result use
this as our as our baseline and all our
comparisons are with respect to this
baseline so one of the things I have to
do before I do anything else is actually
just show you what the you know what the
payoff of this baseline looks like and
what you can show is that looks like mu
star mu a star times T which is like you
know the expected linear reward you
would get if everybody liked a star when
they arrived - some cost which is due to
the fact that there's this initial bias
so you're waiting for the population to
move over to liking a star okay and the
rough idea is that you know where does
this log t come from and I'm telling you
this because it'll play a role later the
idea here is that at each time T when
you're always pulling a
star the probability of the arriving
user likes a star is going to look like
this and what's important in this is
that you have a 1 over T in the second
term okay
it'll also be important that there's
this sum of theta a in the numerator but
I'll explain that to you as it matters
so that's that's where the log T is
coming from here is simply that I have
to sum over this 1 over T okay and so
what we're going to do is measure our
regret of any algorithm that I choose to
tell you about by measuring performance
against this Oracle baseline okay
notably on any finite t it's actually
possible this is negative right because
this is not necessarily optimal for
finite T now synthetically this should
not be negative all right so let's talk
about you know this this result on on
standard bandit learning and what that
tells us so I'm not really going to
spend a lot of time on this slide the
UCB algorithm is this you know standard
benchmark algorithm you've heard about
it a few times now you know basically
the idea is that I pull the arm that has
the largest empirical mean reward plus
some expansion on that estimate which is
this upper confidence bound and the idea
in the upper confidence bound is that
it's I have two terms that are growing
here in principle one which is log T and
the other which is the number of times
I've pulled arm a and the idea behind
this ratio is that what I'm trying to do
is exactly balance the the change in the
upper confidence bound to make sure I
never incur a grab more than log T ok so
this is actually a finite time optimal
algorithm that's the that's the result
of our a tell for this algorithm and
that's the well-known fact for the
standard multi-armed bandit is that you
get a regret of order log T and that's
in fact the best you can do okay so what
happens for this kind of bandit
algorithm with positive externalities as
I already mentioned to you that red blue
example suggests there's at least a
possibility something could go wrong
now how severe is that so it turns out
to be actually quite bad we show that
UCB has linear expected regret okay so
that basically bought as bad as you
could do doing nothing will give you a
linear expected regret right but in fact
the situation is much worse than that if
Paul if you can believe that so the
sense in which the situation is worse
let me parse this for you
so what I'm asking here is what is the
prop
ability that my algorithm never sees a
reward when it pulls a star okay and so
if you think about what this is going to
look like as T gets larger right the
probability of never seeing a reward
when I pull a star should get smaller
because I T is longer now but
nevertheless it remains bounded away
from zero and so what this is saying is
that there's a positive probability of
never receiving a reward on arm a star
with the UCB album and this is actually
the one result that holds fairly
strongly it'll actually hold for any
super logarithmic externality function f
yeah yeah actually that's a really good
question so his question was can I do a
warm start for UCB to sample enough from
each arm and let me come back to that so
you're going to see that this idea of
balancing turns out to be quite
important in fact that's the whole
that's the whole solution to kind of
forecast ahead a little bit so if you
were to do that the fact that you were
using UCB afterwards wouldn't matter
much anymore the important thing is to
figure out how are you going to do that
kind of balanced exploration early on so
I'll talk about that a little bit here
I'm not doing anything particularly
special early on okay and so if you ask
yourself like why does UCB fail and the
intuition is really given by that early
example with red and blue type users the
issue is that it you know and like we
can't blame the algorithm that's not as
if it's coded in the algorithm anyway
but there's no way for it to know that
part of what's happening here is that
the people who are showing up just don't
like the arm so it's trying out so it
didn't even have the chance to see what
me way might have been all right and if
it ignores that fact then it's gonna
stop exploring too quickly on arms that
actually might have been useful so you
know what's a simple benchmark that
explores a bit more so I'm only you'll
see why I'm including this here this
actually is is kind of a waypoint on the
way to talking about what a good
algorithm might be what's a simple
benchmark that explores more so let's
just talk about a very very simple way
to to to kind of balance our exploration
out kind of along the lines of this
question about warm starting and so what
we could do is explore uniformly random
for fixed
time T and then compared commit to the
empirical best armityle for the rest of
the horizon okay and this is basically
what's called random explore than
exploit also Studwell studied and also
gives log t regret for the standard
bandit if you optimize tau so this
actually turns out to be somewhat better
than UCB if you optimize it you get T to
the C regret where C is less than one
okay so at least it's not linear regret
but nevertheless we're not you know the
question remains is this the best you
can do
one of the reasons I wanted to just tell
you about this is simply because this is
a great stochastic networks audience
when you're using re e what's really
nice is that you can map the analysis
over to the analysis of generalized
earned processes so basically the idea
is that you model every single arm
through a continuous time branching
process where branches are occurring at
rate one over m and essentially what
happens every time there's a branching
is that you either go down you either
stay where you are if you didn't get a
successor you go up to two because you
because you you've got a success in this
this increases the positive externality
remember that I'm working with the
linear externality function what's
really nice about this embedding is that
if you now look at the jump chain of the
combined process the behavior of the
jump chain exactly accounts for network
effects it exactly accounts for kind of
what the what the cumulative rewards on
the different arms look like so this is
kind of a nice piece of analysis that
you can see in the paper okay and partly
it's also here for narrative purposes
which is that this was like the second
step in what we tried to do when we
analyzed this problem so we started with
UCB we realized it can fail really badly
than you think about this and you're
like well this is better and then you
ask yourself okay can you know how much
better can things be and so an optimal
algorithm all right clearly needs to
think about this possibility that one of
the reasons I'm not identifying the
optimal arm is that I just didn't have a
chance to observe a reward that whoever
was arriving was not actually someone
who liked like that arm and so you know
that was the issue with UCB if you don't
explore enough then you risk missing the
optimal arm entirely simply because the
riving users don't like it now when we
explore it random okay perhaps we do
have a slightly better job identifying
the optimal arm that's why the regret is
lower it doesn't scale linearly with T
but too much regret is incurred undoing
the bias that was created now on
suboptimal arms right so this is what is
kind of neat about the model is that the
positive externality in order to learn
about an arm you're going to be
attracting users of that type to the
platform and that is going to create a
bias you might have to undo later once
you figure out what the best arm
actually is okay and so what we wanted
to do is you know develop an algorithm
that sort of structures its exploration
more intelligently to overcome these
challenges and that's that's what I'll
tell you about next okay so the balanced
exploration algorithm which is actually
you know a very very simple idea is that
what you do is you fix a towel that
looks like theta log T and for T less
than that tell you pull the arm with the
lowest cumulative reward okay lowest si
and what this is doing is it's it's
essentially trying to make sure that
you're giving every arm ample
opportunity to earn reward so it's your
question about warm starting you need
the warm start in some way but it has to
be sort of structured and and so this is
this turns out to be the right structure
because this is the thing that's
ensuring that that all arms independent
whether they're optimal or not at least
having a chance to generate rewards okay
and this is the the thing I can observe
that's telling me whether or not I'm
seeing enough users who actually like
that arm and then after that I do kind
of the obvious thing I pull the arm with
with the highest mean reward at that
time just the empirical best arm you
could do something more intelligent here
if you wanted to but it it you know that
doesn't end up mattering much right at
least for the regret balance we prove
are all order in T okay and so what we
prove is that this algorithm actually
has regret order log squared T and I
want to tell you a little bit where that
comes from the easiest way to convince
you of where that comes from is actually
to tell you about the lower bound yeah
oh sorry sorry yeah I should have
explained okay si is the total number of
rewards I've earned up to time T and
then this is sorry this is the total
number of times I pull the arm up to
time T so when I take this ratio that's
like the empirical estimate of
yeah that's true yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I think that's a great point so
that's something we've thought about
that you know is kind of one of the
strange things about this exploration
procedure like you almost never see in a
good bandit algorithm something that
looks like but you know this part of it
makes it interesting so I think that
what's happening in the feedback
structure here is the trade off for the
platform is going to be between it's
kind of like choosing failure right so
when am I willing to give up that it's
not worth observing more from a
particular population so if you got down
to the level of worrying about what the
you know what the actual arm parameters
were so trying to characterize these
bounds using actually like distribution
dependent constants then that would have
to play a role in the algorithm and so
yeah by sweeping it under the rug were
kind of able to avoid that one thing we
did do that's it's it's not answering
your question by any means but at least
from a from the perspective of we're
finding the balance we have been able to
extend the bounce at least capture
depends on the number of arms but not in
terms of the actual distributions yeah
yeah you're right so this is fixed T and
then asymptotic in T as opposed to
something that's ongoing that's a great
question so that I was like I'm of two
minds about this I mean you know but I
feel like the right way to think about
that question probably is to pop back to
the platform context and ask the kind of
question that Ava brought up where I
mean if you really wanted to talk about
in dodging a Atia of the user population
for most platforms there's this
dichotomy between growing and succeeding
and failing completely and so really the
only two possible outcomes or something
where you die completely or you've
actually succeeded in your stable and I
think it would be probably you know more
valuable to think about this you know
sort of can you hit this this
exponential growth that gets you out of
out of being stable and that would of
course look very different than what
we're doing here it all comes back to
this issue of this capacity constraints
or the T is T is both fixing I can't get
more or less than that right and you
know when we when we've talked about
this this is one of the things that
we're
it's actually challenging to figure out
how you would model that in a way that
you can you can still get get a get good
learning guarantees yeah it's a great
question you're going to notice this
recurrent theme that I don't have
answers to any of your questions because
this is you know still relatively new
work but I'm trying to answer all their
questions so okay thanks okay so was
there another question yeah yeah that's
what if I was asking exactly so because
of this right I mean essentially what
this is doing so so to be pedantic about
it right the whole idea behind the
algorithm is what's what's causing the
problem the problem is I can't I don't
know for sure that the reason an arm
failed is is that you know I tried it
and that person actually liked it and I
got a zero reward or I tried it and the
person just never liked it in the first
place and so you know one of the issues
with this is that like in order for you
to know that at least this person liked
the arm the only feedback you're gonna
get that's gonna tell you that is
actually getting a reward and that's
basically why this is the thing that you
have to balance exploration on now
coming back davis point and your point
all right i mean a very simple thing
that you could do if you if let's say
you had a lower bound and you said i'm
never gonna be interested in any mu a
that's below this bound that I think
would be fairly easy to incorporate
because that kind of thing you could
just say well you know essentially once
you're certain that nu a is below you
just stop exploring on that arm I think
what's more interesting is to make that
trade-off a bit more dynamic because
that still presumes that you have this
ex ante understanding of what a lower
bound on mu a looks like it would be
nicer to have an algorithm that's
responsive to the actual distributions
that are present without having to know
them in advance yeah
yeah take the arm with the lowest mean
reward yeah Oh pick the lowest mean
reward um that's a good question
let me think my hunches no but I want to
think it over
actually yeah well locally I think it
would be okay but I'm not I don't I'd
have to think through the consequences
from the positive externality
perspective
so let's come back to that maybe we
talked about it offline that's a good
question actually I just want to work
through the lower bound because I only
have at this point two minutes left okay
so lower bound matches its log squared T
as well and I'll quickly give you what
the intuition for the lower bound is
okay so basically the idea and let me
click through it so basically the idea
is that you know as is typical in these
Bandit lower bounds you have to get to
the point where you explored enough on
every arm all right and I want to remind
you of this formula which says that you
know the probability that a user likes a
star is going to look like this if you
happen to be always pulling a star now
what this means is let's say that from
this time theta towel onwards you
correctly identified a start time towel
onwards you correctly identified a star
then what this is telling you is that
you're going to incur regret that looks
like omega of tau log T and the reason
is that you've got the 1 over T still
here and now instead of this bias in the
numerator you've got a bias that comes
from having seen enough successes on all
the other arms okay so you know that
you're gonna get tau log T and then the
last piece of this is very similar to
standard band at lower bounds where the
point is that you can't get away with
getting something then then ole log T
exploration on every arm because
otherwise you don't know so you can use
a change of measure argument to argue
that well if you could split less than
log t then you would incur very high
regret in an alternate universe where
the army words were switched around
right and so that means that this has to
look like log t the towel and if you put
log t into there then you get log
squared T that's a rough idea blower
though okay and so I'll just wrap up by
talking about the drive one more minute
ever okay I just want to wrap up by
talking about what happens is you very
positive externalities and this is sort
of the full picture you
çb always gives you linear regret right
in the case where there's no positive
externalities it actually looks exactly
like a standard bandit problem with all
the rewards scaled down by one over them
and so this is why you see log t
everywhere here alright and so I'll just
point out two interesting things about
this table one is that it's actually
discontinuous at alpha equals 0 and
alpha equals 1 and the reason for this
is that the zero boundary is where you
go from no positive externality to
having a positive externality this since
everything is order and T this
completely changes the behavior of the
of the bounds and then the other piece
of it why does it inflect at alpha
equals 1 this is because of that 1 over
T in the the summation of 1 over T so
alpha equals 1 is exactly the point
where you go from summable to not
summable alright and that's that's kind
of the other piece that causes
discontinuity and what the bounds look
like but those are kind of the main
pieces and in particular the last thing
I'll say on the slide is that balanced
exploration is something which achieves
the lower bound but importantly the
algorithm itself doesn't need to know
what alpha was ok so the thing that's
taking advantage of is that there are
positive externalities but it's not
using information about what the
strength of those positive externalities
were okay all right so I'll wrap up
there I'll just leave this slide up
thank you
[Applause]
yes I yeah yeah yes I said I said that
all buffet days are strictly positive
there's a finite number say yeah oh do
you mean you mean in the lower bound
proof or so you mean on new way not on
theta a sorry on de on de yeah and that
is yeah that's right I think I didn't
say this on the slide I'm assuming all
the mirrors are strictly positive yeah
[Music]
so that is I think that's a great
question and that's this is exactly the
type of thing that I'm hoping this can
like start the prompt so I mean it's not
to your question is if you have
competing platforms do they end up
segmenting the population or yeah and I
don't I don't have any intuition for
that off the top of my head yeah I can
imagine that could go many different
ways depending on the strength of the
externality okay wrap up there thank you
thank you
[Applause]
okay we don't need it when you are
recording okay so